a las 6 de la tarde en punto suena la
alarma antiaérea en la ciudad de mico
live en alerta por los bombardeos rusos
y en el hospital de maternidad número 3
las mujeres embarazadas bajan al búnker
estar acá bajo supervisión de paz hay
médicos para cualquier emergencia lo que
más miedo da es cuando llega el momento
de dar a luz pero te vas a dormir
diciéndote a ti mismo que debes esperar
hasta la mañana hasta que se acabe la
noche
al menos siete mujeres de la sala tienen
previsto dar a luz en breve con gran
preocupación ya que las tropas rusas ya
han atacado varios hospitales del país
desde que estalló el conflicto sobre
todo por los recién nacidos que tienen
una sala especialmente acondicionada
esto es mentalmente agotador porque te
preocupas tanto por ti como por tu bebé
y lo que pasó en una sala de maternidad
el mariupol
qué hago si eso ocurre aquí todo es
horrible una situación tensa también
para el personal médico que a veces se
ven obligados a asistir partos bajo
tierra por seguridad deben evitar subir
al último piso donde se encuentra la
sala de quirófano por lo que de los 49
bebés que han traído al mundo desde la
invasión a ucrania sólo tres han sido
por cesárea
es un gran riesgo porque el quirófano
tiene luces muy grandes y eso nos
convierte en un objetivo para los
bombardeos
cuando nos vemos obligados a usarla
ponemos cortinas pesadas para atenuar la
luz
a pesar de la alarma en algunos casos es
imposible bajar al búnker a las mujeres
que ya están de parto por lo que los
médicos ayudan a traer una nueva vida al
mundo en medio de la penumbra